le 3 novembre les électeurs américains
sont appelés aux urnes d'une échéance
prise très au sérieux par les dirigeants
de facebook tant les événements pourrait
tourner au vinaigre
on sait par exemple que les résultats ne
devraient pas être connus immédiatement
car le vote par correspondance sera à
plébisciter en pleine pandémie
de quoi conduire certains acteurs de
l'élection à contester l'issue du
scrutin
nick clegg le vice président de facebook
s'est livré dans les colonnes du
financial times on y apprend que la
firme américaine a tout prévu en cas de
circonstances dramatiques
nick clegg parle d'options d'urgence
prêtes à être mises en place au cas où
facebook ferait face je cite à des
circonstances chaotiques
voire pire violente on a déjà agi dans
d'autres parties du monde où il y avait
une réelle instabilité sociale et on a
les outils de toute évidence sans donner
plus de détails sur ces outils nick
clegg évoque la possibilité de réduire
la circulation de certains contenus sur
la plateforme
des précédents existent notamment au sri
lanka ou en birmanie ou facebook avait
réduit la portée de publication jugée
borderline mais qui ne l'est pas
forcément les règles sur les discours de
haine
il faudra donc peut-être s'en remettre à
nouveau l'arbitrage des dirigeants de
facebook
cette communication volontariste du
vice-président du réseau social vise
surtout à effacer la mauvaise image de
l'entreprise en matière de régulation
des contenus
voilà plusieurs mois que facebook fait
un grand ménage ciblant notamment les
propos haineux en juillet dernier mark
zuckerberg a affirmé devant le congrès
américain que 89% des discours de haine
était supprimée de manière proactive
avant qu'il ne puisse être vu par
d'autres utilisateurs
après le scandale cambridge analytica le
géant du web et désireux de montrer
patte blanche
encore plus en période électorale c'est
sans doute pour cette raison que
l'entreprise a lancé un vaste programme
visant à encourager ses utilisateurs à
s'inscrire sur la liste électorale
objectif inciter 4 millions de personnes
à s'inscrire mais derrière cette
apparente philanthropie se cache peut
être des but non avoué
c'est en tout cas la crainte de cette
professeure américaine spécialisée dans
les réseaux sociaux
les entreprises sont des entités
politiques et nous ne devrions pas
croire que la plate forme d'inscription
des électeurs est fait avec pour seul
objectif le bien public et n'est pas
aussi stratégique
leurs efforts pour inscrire des
électeurs pourraient servir les
objectifs d'une entreprise et nous
devons nous assurer qu'il ne procède pas
de manière stratégique dans une voie qui
pourrait fausser l'élection et il ya
effectivement de quoi s'interroger quel
type de population est visée par cette
campagne facebook cibles telles
indirectement un électorat plus qu'un
autre à vouloir trop en faire pour ne
plus être accusée de laxisme facebook
risque peut-être de glisser vers
d'autres dérives qui pourraient s'avérer
lourd de conséquences